all right this one I hope you're sitting
down for or or at least braced or
attached to something because this is
like nothing I have ever seen just when
it seems as though there is nowhere else
to go there is no place to hide for
Donald Trump now that this audio tape
has come out where Trump is clearly
heard shuffling papers and saying these
are secret documents these are
classified documents I can't show you
this stuff I shouldn't be showing you
this stuff Trump was interviewed
yesterday after his speech in New
Hampshire by the publication semaphore
and Trump's new claim is he wasn't
actually holding up any documents it was
just like golf related documents
uh he's you can hear him shuffling
papers he's saying these are secret
documents but there weren't actually any
documents he was just playing it up look
at this article this is by Shelby
Talcott for semaphore it was bravado
Trump says he wasn't holding up
classified documents in the 2021 meeting
referred to on the tape
look at these quotes I would say it was
bravado if you want to know the truth it
was bravado Trump said in an interview a
board is playing with semaphore and ABC
News I was talking and just holding up
papers and talking about them but I had
no documents I didn't have any documents
um the late the latest comments
suggested a new potential legal argument
from Trump that he was overselling the
material he was showing to an aide and
people working on a biography of Mark
Meadows in a recording quote I just held
up a whole pile of my desk is loaded up
with papers I have papers from 25
different things he said adding he kept
relevant news articles about topics like
Iran on hand at one point Trump gestured
to the seat next to him on the plane
were a stack of various papers
newspapers copies of a speech printouts
of article sat he grabbed some from the
pile and placed them in front of him
moving the route moving them around as
he spoke and offering up a physical
reenactment of what he said was
occurring on the audio tape did I use
the word plans what I'm referring to is
magazines newspapers plans of buildings
I had plans of buildings you know
building plans I had plans for a golf
course asked if he had any regrets about
his handling of classified documents
Trump said no
no I have no regrets I didn't have a
classified document there was no
classified document on my desk
wow
um this is like nothing I've ever seen
or heard of the here's the new position
yes Trump does refer to documents on the
audio recording yes you hear papers
shuffling around yes there were papers
on Trump's desk and yes Trump uses the
word plans but these were not classified
plans to attack Iran these were Golf
Course plans for for a golf course Trump
planned to build and he was just trying
to impress the people around him now of
course the problem is
there are witnesses who have testified
that these really were documents related
to military plans and defense
information that's a little bit of a
problem it may be a problem if Trump
tries to use this argument in court
um and of course the other problem is
that this is explanation number seven or
eight for the exact same thing there
were classified documents but they were
Declassified oh there were classified
documents but I had the right to have
them and they are de facto Declassified
just by virtue of me having them oh
there were no documents at all there
were papers but they weren't classified
documents there were classified
documents but I didn't take them the FBI
planted them or there might have been
some documents and boxes along with
clothes and mementos as these people
call them I don't know why they say
momentos instead of the word mementos
they just make up words I don't know uh
but it's it's just completely crazy now
I want to add one other commentary here
and I think that this is an important
thing to mention
there are some people on the
Revolutionary left I I know that some
people call them tankies I'm trying to
be as least pejorative as possible the
the sort of like pro-putin left the
Revolutionary left the folks who like
Maduro and Venezuela or Castro or these
types of folks there are some on the
Revolutionary left who are saying this
is I'm not even going to name names this
is this entire leaked audio recording
story is another example of the
corporate media
ignoring the good things about Trump
these plans to attack Iran Trump didn't
want to attack Iran I got a few emails
about this from revolutionary left to
saying David why won't you be honest and
tell the real story the real story is
the media hates Trump because when he
was given that plan to attack Iran he
didn't want to do it now there's a whole
bunch of different things that could be
said including that presidents are
presented with every option all the time
and the idea that someone was pushing
him to attack Iran and he didn't want to
do it we don't even know that to be true
but you have to remember Trump has no
idea what he's for or against he might
be for or against attacking Iran today
he might have been for or against
attacking Iran on the day that he was
presented with those plans or on the day
that he showed someone it doesn't matter
Trump doesn't know anything about Iran
he doesn't know anything about foreign
policy it is irrelevant to whether Trump
committed the crimes for which he's been
arrested whether on that day or on the
day before or on the day after
he wanted to attack Iran or not and the
Revolutionary leftists who are saying
there's no story here other than Trump
really was against Wars and he was
against war with Iran you were just flat
out wrong that is not the story here the
story here is they've got Trump dead to
rights on an audio recording committing
the exact crimes that he's been charged
for now what is his lawyer saying about
it let's talk about that next
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description